hey it's Justine and today I'm going to
be showing you the brand new invisible
dive case for the insta 360 x through
camera you guys have seen me review
these cameras in the past and I just
recently got into diving so we're gonna
take two of my favorite things the
insta360 X3 camera and Diving and put
them together so of course this is a 360
camera so you'll see it has two lenses
one on the front one on the back and it
has a large LCD so you'll be able to
actually see what you're filming it's
also going to be a montage so
you know
[Music]
so this can shoot up to 5 7K in 360. you
can shoot 72 megapixel 360 degree photos
it has active HDR Flow State
stabilization a 360 degree Horizon lock
and it's waterproof up to 10 meters or
33 feet it's got voice control and AI
editing you can also use this in a 4K
single lens mode so it will only use one
of the lenses so you won't have to worry
about editing 360 footage
now with the dive case this will make
the camera waterproof up to 164 feet or
50 meters this will give you crystal
clear 360 video and seamless underwater
stitching and of course this is the
invisible dive case so you won't have to
worry about seeing the bottom of the
case or the selfie stick oh look how
cool it is whoa like where am I going to
go and test this out I don't know need
to find somewhere cool our little baggy
and
I don't know what these things are yet
but we're gonna find out
so here's the case let's open it up I
like that this gives you access to the
buttons so you can fully control it
underwater it does say that if you do
use this in salt water you want to rinse
it or soak it in fresh water for about
60 Minutes to make sure that none of the
salt crystals or anything starts to form
on it oh so those little things are
anti-fog inserts
that makes sense so you just put those
right inside so let's see how this fits
I mean are we surprised it's a perfect
fit the thing that I love so much about
insta360 is their editing software you
can edit in their insta360 studio app on
a desktop or you can import the footage
directly to your phone and edit on the
go they have all kinds of AI editing
which makes it super fun and easy to
import your footage as soon as you're
done filming and get something edited
and posted right away now this can be
also used for diving so you don't have
to go down far depths but this Dome is
specifically designed for really just
shooting underwater scenarios so if you
do use this above the water it's not
going to quite perform the way that it
should so underwater only speaking of
which let's uh let's go find some water
and and hop it
foreign
[Music]
360 invisible dive case and I am
currently in Hawaii and I'm having so
much fun testing this out I recently got
Open Water certified so this trip would
have made my 15th and 16th Dives ever
now I am new to diving but cameras and
Tech are something that I'm not new at
and especially when it comes to the
insta 360 because I'm obsessed with
these cameras what I love so much using
these top side is the fact that it is a
360 camera which means you can hold it
out and everything around you is being
filmed but why this is so incredible
especially for Content creators is you
don't have to worry about getting the
shot because you can find the shot later
you're filming everything now of course
this does carry through to underwater
but underwater things are a little bit
different especially as you start diving
deeper one of the things that I noticed
is how good this looked in really great
lighting my sister did more snorkeling I
did more diving so in those deeper
depths as long as you have decent
lighting the footage is going to look
really good and crisp the deepest that I
dove was about 98 feet which for me that
is so far my record and it really is a
whole different experience when you're
filming underwater especially at those
depths because the perspective
everything sort of changes and with the
lack of lighting you definitely have to
be more conscious about how you're
filming so we did have a flashlight
which really helped in getting some of
these shots now the appeal of the
invisible dive case is the fact that you
can hold this out and everywhere that
you film will be viewable and the selfie
stick will be masked out now there was a
previous version of this which I never
tried since I'm so new to underwater
activities that you can see here in this
example footage you can actually see the
case so that's why this new one is so
special because it was developed to make
the case invisible
[Music]
thank you
how I mostly was filming a lot of this
content was holding it straight out in
front of you and because it is 360 like
I said you can go in and reframe all of
these shots so you'll see here I'm in
the insta360 studio app and this allows
me to go and scroll around I can use
keyframes I can change the perspective
and I can figure out all of the things
that I want to see so for example we
swam into the shark cave so this is all
the same shot this is me looking at the
shark and this is the shark that I'm
looking at so I'm able to just hold this
out in front and get both of those shots
and it's so easy to edit on the go on
your phone like I can take all of this
stuff as soon as we're finished diving
sync it to my phone and start editing
and getting some clips to post to social
if you guys are interested in the insta
360 and the dive accessories I'll put a
link in the description a huge thank you
to insta360 for partnering with me on
this video I am such a huge fan of their
cameras and I'm so appreciative of how
supportive they've been in my channel
and they're just incredible and I'm so
excited to see what you guys think of
this thank you guys so much for watching
if you have any dive suggestions or
places that I should visit please leave
them in the comments below and I look
forward to reading those see you later